das ist elefantenbaby kieran aus dem
leipziger zoo
er liebt es sich im schlamm zu holen
oder im wasser mit mama rani zu
planschen
lange war kieran das sorgenkind der
tierpfleger viele wochen ging es dem
neun monate alten elefanten bohlen sehr
schlecht dass er jetzt so ausgelassen
spielt grenzt an ein kleines wunder
kieran nahm seit seiner geburt im januar
nie richtig zu monatelang bangte dazu um
das leichtgewicht mittlerweile wiegt er
2 126 kilo leider immer noch zu wenig
für ein jungtier seines alters offiziell
gibt es also noch keine entwarnung vom
zog iran muss noch ordentlich zulegen
trotz zu wenig kilos auf den rippen ist
der kleine elefantenbulle aber ein
ziemlich aufgewecktes burschen mit
seiner mama und tante dort um die
natürlich immer auf den kleinen
wirbelwind aufpassen müssen flitzt er
über die leipziger zoo anlage hieran ist
auf dem weg der besserung und wir
drücken ganz fest die daumen dass er
bald über den bug ist